boston is the university capital of the
united states
there was a lot of rich kids who just
wanted to smoke pot and it was a perfect
market for us
we felt indestructible people were
getting hired they loved our product
[Music]
our business grew and became successful
we had this big pile of cash plenty of
women and we were just having a blast
[Music]
and then one night i met this colombian
guy
and he told me there's someone i should
meet in colombia
this guy in colombia he runs an
organization cartel that grows 50 tons
of marijuana a year
and we call him el pedrino the godfather
he knows you
he wants to meet you
i was 20 years old and some godfather in
colombia had heard about me and they
wanted me to go to columbia to meet them
that got me excited
this was a big opportunity
columbia was known to have top quality
marijuana and here was my chance to get
right to the source
it was dangerous and breathtaking and
scary but the thing is i'm a high-risk
junkie
i had a need to always push things to
the limit
to build something and keep building it
and building it until it blew up
[Music]
so the next morning
i was in a private plane
flying into northern columbia
to meet the godfather
and he says come on in
you look like someone who was deadly
serious the mysterious hard-wired kind
of person
the feeling that i had was a feeling of
distrust
i'm not sure what's going on here i'm
out of my elements
[Music]
we get about 10 miles down the road and
we get to a military checkpoint
the godfather handed me the bag
with this
i open the bag and i see 50 000
pesos and i see it revolving
and he says to me
i want you
to offer the guard the pesos first
and if he doesn't take it
i want you to shoot him
what have i got myself into
then i realize this is a test
they want to know
if i've got the balls
to go out there and actually shoot
someone in the head who doesn't take a
bribe
so i had no choice
i had the money and the gun
there was so many thoughts going through
my head i hate violence i've always
hated violence and i didn't want to
shoot him
so i really hoped that he would take
that money
the guide looked at me
i looked at him
i take a deep breath
and hand him the bag of money
i could tell
that he was bewildered
i needed him to take that money
he looked at me
and slowly walked back towards the god
house
through the bag
i thought thank god
and then i walked
back and he asked is everything okay
[Music]
and i said yes
going on that journey was
that was the test right
he's challenging me to see who's the
craziest in the room is it him or is it
me
as we got deeper into the jungle
we got to a farmhouse
i noticed that there were farm workers
who were also carrying shotguns and
rifles
it was clear to me at that point in time
he was running a very serious operation
and then
as we got over the hill i could see down
in the valley as far as my eyes could
see the most beautiful crop of marijuana
plants
i'd never seen so much marijuana in my
life
this was at least 20 000 acres
this is unbelievable this is probably
the largest marijuana field in the world
the godfather explains to me
that they've been growing here
for 120 years
and distributing a crop in south
america
and then he got down to business
the godfather wanted to know
is it possible to move mountains of
marijuana
safely from this farm to the u.s
their hobbies is 50 tons per year
and i thought that's a lot of cubic
footage it seems insane
and then he said i'll give me
he walked me to this barn
[Music]
when he opened the door
there was like floor floor-to-ceiling
u.s currency
there were just hundreds of bales of
cash
[Music]
i just looked at that money
and i thought
i loved this guy
and then i fell in love with this
project
then the godfather told me it would make
me filthy rich that i would make 10 to
13
million dollars a year
i said perfect
i've been doing the same on a very small
scale
but i know how this works now
so i said yes
and i'm in
but then he said
once you agree
you can't get out until i say you're
free to go
i had no idea what kind of impact that
would have on my life
[Music]
you